all right so assessing the situation are
they breathing no rose they are not
breathing and they have no arms or legs
no that's not part of it where are they
you know what if we come across somebody
with no arms or legs do we bother
resuscitating them I mean what kind of
quality of life do we have there I would
want to live with no legs how about no
arms no arms or legs is basically how
you exist right now Kevin you don't do
anything all right well let's get back
to it cuz you're losing him okay too
fast everyone we need to pump at a pace
of 100 beats per minute oh okay that's
hard to keep track how many is that per
hour
sounds like an Albu I will divide and
then count to it what okay well a good
trick is to pump to the tune of staying
alive by the Bee Gees yes yes I do first
I was afraid I was petrified no you were
in the park that's how I know you stay
alive
[Music]
staying alive okay you didn't maintain
100 beats per minutes and the ambulance
didn't arrive because nobody called 911
okay he's dead
anyone know what we do next anybody Rose
I have no idea anyone else we bury him
wrong ant check for an organ donor card
if he has one we only have minutes to
harvest
he has no wallet I checked he is an
organ donor yes yeah give me some ice in
a styrofoam bucket here we go we search
for the organs where's the hard precious
hard I'm not feeling well I need to tell
me why you had to cut the face off the
dummy I didn't think it was very
realistic in the movie and it turns out
it's pretty realistic we had to pay for
it cost us thirty five hundred dollars
five thousand three hundred dollars for
a dummy Wow well okay look David this is
why we have training we start with the
dummy and we learn from our mistakes and
now Dwight knows not to cut the vision
for a real person
you